well for the last several years pretty
much every Investment Bank and business
journalist in the United States has
joined in the ongoing orgy of praise for
a man called Sam bankman freed the head
of the crypto exchange FTX somehow no
one noticed that he was basically a
child wearing shorts who played video
games during interviews and didn't seem
to understand how his company was making
money but they lauded him as the world's
first future trillionaire they all fell
for it well not all a very few didn't
they saw right through it Elon Musk for
example said he
took one look at bankman freed and his
BS detector went off and then at much
greater length and depth last March the
CEO of CME Group a man called Terry
Duffy met with Sam bankman freed and
during that meeting Duffy did what
pretty much nobody else did maybe nobody
else at all ever did he called Sam
bankman free to quote absolute fraud to
his face which of course he turned out
to be then in May Terry Duffy kept going
he tried to warn Congress about FTX and
Sam bankman freed here's what happened
I'm asking you sir you have a saying so
that FTX has quote no Capital
requirements for participants I I think
that's on its face a false statement
given that the cftc port 39 regulation
requires Capital requirements and FDX
does have a capital requirement for uh
for margins I said their Capital
requirements are not the same as they
are for other institutions capital is
capital is not the same as margin
Congressman sorry
so rokana Democrat of Silicon Valley
getting emotional as he defends Sam
bankman Freedom FTX why is that maybe
someone will do a story to find out why
but in the meantime we are grateful to
have Terry Duffy join us he's the CEO of
CME Group a man who has been completely
Vindicated why do you and thank you so
much for coming on tonight why do you
and by the way I should recommend to our
viewers there's a whole lot of tape that
we don't have time to play of you making
this case at Great length on the
internet and it's worth watching but why
do you think you're one of the only
people to get this right
I don't know Tucker it's a great
question but I appreciate you having me
on I appreciate you playing that piece
from with the genius from California to
tell me how crypto markets work and the
difference between capital what I was
referring to is excess margin which CME
holds over 200 billion dollars where FTX
was having regulatory Capital which is
absolutely nothing so he didn't know the
difference between regulatory capital
and margin Capital so it made me laugh
but you know really dismissive when it
comes to a guy like that so I don't know
why people didn't see a Tucker you know
I mean I I said to my team I said you
know this is not about crypto Tucker
this is about him trying to change the
world so he could list every single
product under the scam that he was
trying to do with crypto the crypto is
so small but if he could deploy his
model in the U.S treasury market in the
U.S agricultural Market can you imagine
the damage this human being could have
done to our country in the world I mean
and people literally literally were
turning a blind eye to it when you look
at the people that were with him Tucker
Mark Widgeon a former head of the cftc
the chairman he's walking around with
this guy as his you know baggage handler
in acting giving him credibility the
former counsel for the cftc became his
EV his General counselor at FTX the
former head of the ad committee Mike
Conaway is is his consultant working the
room across both sides of the aisle I
mean it's absolutely an embarrassment
what went on here and nobody bothered to
look at it I said he could lose 85
percent of his value in a single day
Tucker I said that in Congressional
testimony I did not know how right I
would be in such a short period of time
it was a completely fraught proposal
what he was doing I knew he was a fraud
the day I met him and it was quite easy
to pick out
well so you assessed his character and
his Vibe because you met with in person
but you also assessed you know the the
fundamentals of his company as someone
involved in business would why did none
of the Regulators do that where was Gary
Gensler
well I don't know where Gary Gensler was
but my regulator at the cftci bribe I
asked them why in the world are you
invoking the commodity exchange act
Section 5 paragraph B which says the
commission will entertain Innovation It
also says in that same part of the act
that you will protect Market under
surveillance and everything else to
protect the consumers that are using
those markets they were using that I
want to know was there pressure put on
the agency from politicians or not and
there's hearings coming up I hope
someone has the courage to take on the
commission to the cftc and others and
ask them why they were trying to put a
round hole in a square peg they should
have dismissed his proposal out of hand
instead I was forced to go into Congress
get berated by people that don't know
what they're talking about and I told
them what could potentially happen and
again it did happen
amazing I just want to recommend again
to our viewers Terry Duffy is the name
of our current guest and if you want if
you want a happy evening look up his
assessment of fbx is just it's just
amazing I appreciate your coming on
Terry Duffy thank you Tucker you're the
best thank you sir